- - La ménopause, c'est une
loloterie. Tu peux piger deux
sysymptômes, 10 symptômes, ou le
jajackpot. Moi, j'ai pigé le
jajackpot.
- - Quand j'ai entendu le mot
"h"hormone bioidentique" là j'ai
fafait : Oh my god! Ça...
- - Ça, ça t'as ouvert une
nouvelle porte?
- - Oui.
- - J'espère faire bouger les
afaffaires pour que ce soit
cocouvert parce que ça coûte chr
etet parce que peu de médecins n
cece moment offrent cette optio.
JeJe veux comprendre pourquoi
c'c'est pogné de même, puis on
pepeut-tu "shaker" la boîte pour
quque ça bouge.
- - Les femmes, il faut se batte
popour avoir une hormonothérapie
lala plus sécuritaire possible.
ThThat's it, that's all.
DeDes images de la bande-annonce
dede Loto Méno, une série
dodocumentaire dans laquelle
onon suit la quête de
VéVéronique Cloutier pour
trtrouver de l'information
susur la périmonépause.
A Au départ, elle voulait faire
cecette série pour dire aux fems
ququ'elles ne sont pas seules à
vivivre les effets de ces
bobouleversements hormonaux
ququi restent encore tabous
auaujourd'hui. Elle était loin e
sese douter que ça aurait autant
d'd'impact et qu'elle y trouvert
dedes injustices sur les
trtraitements offerts aux femmes
ququi se ressent jusque dans
leles cabinets des médecins.
MoMon invitée, Dre Sylvie Demer,
esest l'une des protagonistes de
lala série. Elle est une pionnie
enen recherche sur les hormones
féféminines bio-identiques et
l'l'hormonothérapie au Québec.
BoBonsoir. Vous êtes une pionnie
enen recherche sur les hormones
féféminines bioidentiques.
C'C'est un sujet encore mystérix
etet vous dîtes que vous dénoncz
quque les femmes ont peu accès à
cecette information.
- - Les femmes ont peu accès ete
didirais même que les médecins t
pepeu accès. On n'a pas beaucoup
dede formation sur le rôle des
hohormones féminines en dehors u
sysystème reproducteur. On n'a s
bebeaucoup d'informations sur ls
didifférences entre les types
d'd'hormones. Il y a beaucoup de
trtravail à faire.
- - Pourtant quand on est dans e
cacabinet du médecin et qu'on
paparle symptômes de Perry
méménopause, on pense aux bouffs
dede chaleur entre autres, ont
prprescrit des hormones mais vos
ddîtes qu'il y a des classes
d'd'hormones dont parle presque
jajamais dans les cabinets de
mémédecins.
NeNe pas de quoi vous parlez
avavant. Pouvez-vous nous
exexpliquer en quoi c'est
didifférent d'hormones qu'on se
fafait prescrire?
- - Ça veut dire que ce sont des
hohormones dont la structure
ShShimmins est pareille aux
hohormones que les ovaires
prproduisent et ça a les mêmes
acactions dans le corps des
fefemmes. Ça n'a rien de nouvea.
CÇa existe depuis aussi longtems
quque l'hormonothérapie classiqe
etet ça a fait l'objet de normes
ététudes en laboratoire et c'est
çaça qui est étudiée. C'est
vrvraiment...
l'l'hormonothérapie, on n'est ps
àà jour tout ce qui se fait au
niniveau scientifique et je lisà
totous les jours et j'apprends
plplein de choses.
- - Qu'est-ce que ces les
avavantages?
- - Quand on mélange tous les
tytypes d'hormonothérapie, quand
leles femmes commencent avant
l'l'âge de 60 ans ou à moins de0
anans de la mine pose, dans les
ététudes contrôlées, il y a une
didiminution de mortalité qui
ararrive en 30 et 39 %. Dans une
ététude qui a fait peur à
l'l'échelle planétaire, il y avt
dede la mortalité jusqu'à 31 %.l
y y avait beaucoup d'avantages à
prprendre de l'hormonothérapie.n
fafait peur à cause des risquest
ilil y a toujours le mot risqueà
lala bouche, le risque et on pae
totoujours de risque et jamais e
bibienfaits alors que les
bibienfaits sont très nombreux.
L'L'hormonothérapie pour faire a
cocour, c'est parce qu'on a pase
ririsque. D'hormonothérapie
clclassique parce que dans le
ririsque..
ilil y a le risque de cancer du
sesein, d'infarctus et des
cacaillots...
elelle augmente le risque de
cacaillots plus que les oestrogs
etet c'est la substance qui état
reresponsable du cancer du sein
dadans les études, pas les
oeoestrogènes ou la progestéront
ququi était aussi responsable ds
ininfractions Huth. Ce que je vx
unune hormonothérapie la plus
popossible. Quand on parle
d'd'efficacité parce que les
hohormones ont parle...
ilil faut savoir qu'avec
l'l'hormonothérapie bio identiqe
paparce qu'on peut la doser et
çaça a des effets très différen.
OnOn va parler de la progestéroe
etet on va avoir un effet sur le
reremboursé par la RAMQ
cocontrairement aux autres
hohormones..
cocomment vous expliquez ça?
- - Les hommes ont de choses. La
tetestostérone est une hormone
imimportante et on ne peut pas e
momodifier chimiquement. On se t
ququ'il ne faut pas le modifier
elelle est trop importante et on
rereconnaît le rôle de la
tetestostérone en dehors du
sysystème reproducteur. On a jue
àà penser à la force musculaire,
lala libido, l'énergie. Tandis e
leles femmes on les méprise. On
esest dans un contexte de
mimisogynie hormonale.
IlIl y a un paquet de rôles que
leles médecins n'apprennent past
c'c'est incroyable comment il yn
a.a. Ça touche tout le système.
- - Ça fait parti des tabous...
unune sorte d'injustice dont sot
vivictimes les femmes parce qu'n
nene parle pas assez et c'est ce
quque Véronique Cloutier parle.
PaParce qu'on n'en parle pas one
papas d'attention et on reste ac
dedes secrets et on reste avec e
méméconnaissance qui va jusque
dadans le cabinet médical.
- - Il y a vraiment un mépris.
CeCe sont des hormones qui ont
énénormément de fonction dans le
cocorps des femmes et si les
fefemmes vivent plus longtemps e
leles hommes à cause des hormons
féféminines. Ce qu'il faudrait
c'c'est qu'elle a prie ménopause
c'c'est à peu près la moitié de
l'l'espérance de vie des femmes.
C'C'est un enjeu majeur qui
dedevrait être considéré.
- - C'est un sujet passionnant
mamais il faut qu'on se laisse.
J'J'invite les gens à regarder e
trtravail de Madame Cloutier. Ça
fafait vraiment un tabac.